so will crow takes them out for the
final time in 2021 his rookie season
takes that mound with a record of four
and eight and a five seventy seven
earned run average and there's another
walk the second issued by crow two on
for joey vano
and pops it up
first pitch
and the infield fly is called
oh that was almost needed
[Applause]
this ball's popped up
and that catch is made we'll pick that
up we go to the bottom of the first as
cole tucker
will be leading things off luis castillo
happy nino day has the start castillo
trying to finish off the season on a
high note
there's a line drive base hitting the
right center and at least a couple there
goes the helmet that's a given now does
he get three cole tucker heads to third
and he's there with a trip trip triple
to start the bottom of the first
broken back roller that'll do the trick
one nothing pirate sutsugo picks up his
25th rbi as a bucco
0-2 check swing and yes he went and he
knew it
yes he did
and they're a couple to start this
second
and then he strikes out the side in
order one nothing here's the center of
the 1-1 and newman lines one pass short
into left base hit
perez had to make sure it went through
he'll move up to second back-to-back
singles for the pirates and there's a
walk to load them up for will crow
[Applause]
struck him out second k for castillo
india
the overhand lob and the leap of loading
and a pop-up
got to get there
tucker makes a tumbling catch in foul
territory
a long way great play by cole tucker
and he goes down another strikeout for
crow finally got him a sport strikeout
two and two on him and the pitch
swinging a miss struck him out as crow
registers his fifth strikeout tonight
crow has the strikeout pitch going three
straight
six on the night
that's going to be just a lazy routine
fly ball
heading over
one two three
for will crow one nothing
three two swinging a miss struck him out
going back to back off speed pitches and
a seventh strikeout tonight for crow
wow how about it
eight strikeouts for will crow
castillo with three k's two have come at
crow's expense
and strike three called and castillo
retires the pirates one two three in the
fifth we go to the sixth
here's the one two and swinging a miss
he struck him out is that that
two-seamer again
sends this to center field will crow's
gonna for the second time in his career
pitch six
shutout innings and
he's not done yet you wouldn't think
he's rolling
here is
alford who grounds one into left base
hit and that'll move miranda second
offered with his second hit tonight two
are aboard
the pitch swinging and a miss down on
strikes michael perez
struck him out
back-to-back case for sims he strands a
couple of inherited runners and
castillo's era will end the year in the
threes
[Applause]
somebody else in
cole tucker makes an unbelievable catch
throws to first
[Applause]
that is incredible
call tucker you just made
maybe the catch of the year in this
ballpark
on fan appreciation weekend
this is incredible
that's incredible
it bounces up and makes it a double play
wow
incredible oh
that is time for unreal
the 2-2 and it's a bouncing ball deep
short fielded by newman this is a second
one no late
everybody's safe friedel beats out the
lead throw two on for mac shrunk
runners go
schrock sends it to right that's down
base hit freidle sent home shusugo from
right throws to second freidel scores
stevenson the third max schrock connects
on a game-tying single and it's one all
that's the first professional appearance
in the outfield for tyler stevenson
swinging a fly ball to left stevenson in
his first game ever in left field traps
the ball against the ground and
everyone's going to be safe can't make
the play now you got bases loaded in one
out big situation for the pirates
gets away
here comes otsugo
the pirates take the lead
wild pitch by lorenzen scores tsutsugo
and little up the middle action base hit
moran and alford score of the two run
single by kevin newman
this ball lined in the right field of
base hit cora will wave home perez
and there's an rbi single for park
5-1 bucks
tucker tonight started the game with a
triple infield still out but the bases
full of buckos
[Applause]
tucker it's your night
it's a great slam
for cole
tucker putting an exclamation point on a
fantastic night
what an unbelievable night for cole
tucker the best game of his major league
career
[Applause]
pereiro to center reynolds back
off his glove suarez scores
guerrero through second he challenges
for three
they missed the cut-off man and
marrero's got third base it's a 9-2 game
and the man from mars
will win that battle raise the jolly
roger old tucker
and himself a knight